i wield the power they cannot what's up
everyone blizzcon 2016 just kicked off
today we watched its keynote we got some
more news about the new overwatch
character but merry as a diablo fan
you're probably more excited to see more
stuff about diablo 3 yeah and everybody
was really anticipating some kind of
news about diablo whether that be diablo
for a large expansion turns out they had
some really good news for fans of the
original diablo they are recreating and
putting diablo one in diablo 3 yeah it's
gonna be 16 dungeon levels I believe
you're accessing it through somewhere in
nutrition room at the beginning of the
game I'd imagine original four bosses
from the first diablo greenie pixelated
art style they said only eight movement
directions for your character so it's
not a 360 degrees that diablo 3 has yeah
what is like a diablo fan are you more
excited for this and you would've been
for like potential like new game i guess
it's kind of an obvious question but
yeah how do you feel about this being
like in a patch in diablo 3 i think a
lot of fans were hoping for maybe a
diablo for a new expansion but fans of
this original trilogy there's nothing
better than being able to recreate the
original diablo in the way that it was
meant to be played so i'm getting those
eight directions getting the authentic
style and they're come Cera adding all
the original music and sound effects so
two people who really really want to
have that authentic experience now you
can experience that in diablo 3 I mean
that is something really cool and that
something diehard fans are going to want
so I'm really excited to play that and
to a degree I don't know if I actually
needed a Diablo for like I felt pretty
good with this trilogy so for you know
an actual like a true fan this is
actually not this is good and I like
this and I'm excited to play it but in
addition to giving us Diablo one within
diablo 3 they also announced a new
character class yeah so the necromancer
class from diablo 2 is making a comeback
it'll be be seventh class in diablo 3
and they showed a short teaser trailer
just like obviously reviving skeletons
arriving dead they're talking about like
exploding corpses and whatnot all the
armor like the art direction which I
love in diablo 3 looks like it's
transferring over the necromancer like
his shoulder his pauldrons were like a
like skulls with horns on them and then
he turned around had a scythe was looked
like his base weapon and of course
like in the gameplay they showed the
brief gameplay he's got like an army of
skeletons running behind him the witch
doctor had some necromancy abilities but
it was more like geared like around like
these jungle creatures kind of whereas
this looks like I mean like if it's
anything like the able to you're
actually reviving enemies you've killed
so that could be an interesting mechanic
and I'm curious to see how that's going
to fit into like four-person teams from
the original six classes sorry the
original five classes plus the Crusader
plus the new necromancer I'm pretty
eager to try that out that'll be on
public test realm next week for PC yeah
it says that they're going to do a
little bit more deep dive into those
character classes later on during
blizzcon so there will be way more
information on that soon but there was
definitely a gap right for people who
even using the witch doctor had to force
their way into a necromancer build so
this is kind of filling in those
character classes much more so for
people who always wanted that back from
like the old days are like Diablo and
yellow to now you're getting that
character class that you've wanted so
that's a really nice addition to kind of
completing this game and then they're
also announced two new areas yeah if
you're like me and you prefer adventure
mode now that you've beaten the story
like six or seven times the two new
zones are accessible through the bounty
map in adventure mode one is the
shrouded Moors yeah there's a temple of
the firstborn so even with your original
characters will still be a little bit of
new content to play but yet for more
from blizzcon 2016 we have a couple
people down there and hopefully i'm sure
they'll get their hands on the
necromancer as well as somber than you
cared from overwatch which we also have
news about but in general for more news
out of blizzcon 2016 stay tuned to
gamespot thanks for stopping by ah of
the Dead
shall rise and why come on